hey how's it going hi Evan wow this
micro kitchen sure are getting bigger I
know so much chocolate anyways machine
learning has been all the Crace lately
and we're looking for better and faster
ways to leverage it but we often run
into operational overhead especially
considering all the time and effort it
takes to develop a specific model and
haven't run in different places yeah I
actually hear this issue a lot a common
scenario is that a data scientist would
develop his or her model on a laptop
train that model in the cloud then serve
it in production maybe on Prem or in a
different cloud in these different
environments software and hardware
configurations to totally be different
that makes things break easily we're
moving from one environment to the other
so what if I told you that there will be
a way to easily develop training and
deployment learning models in the very
scalable and flexible way by leveraging
kubernetes wow that would be amazing do
you think you could show us all about in
five minutes for sure I will be using an
open-source framework to do just that it
is called queue flow it helps you run
machine learning models on kubernetes
well I will show you how to use to flow
to first train a tensor flow model to
recognize handwritten numbers then to
serve that model on an application
server on top of that we will deploy a
web interface to interact with the model
over a public Internet so cute flow
actually supports distributed training
as well as training on GPUs but to keep
things simple today I will demo CPU only
training on a single node let's jump
into it let's do it
I have already spun up a crewman a
de-stressor cube Flo uses a tool called
K sana to help manage kubernetes
development packages to get started
first I deploy cute flow component to my
kubernetes cluster some of these
component include a Jupiter hub for
model development and TF job for
managing training jobs
after those are deployed
I can run cube control get all and see a
list of all the resources provision by
cube flow now that cube flow is ready to
go let's start training the model it's
actually really easy
I have already built a container was
existing Python cold and pushed it to
the container registry this Python code
trains the model to recognize
handwritten digits then export the model
to a storage bucket
now I will deploy the training component
I set the parameters for the training
drop to tell it where to find the
container in the registry you can now
see in the workflow page I have a
container being created to perform the
training job when it is done the model
will be exported to a bucket it is going
to take a little while spinning up the
container and doing the actual training
while this is happening let's set up a
server to serve the model I'm using a TF
serving deployment to do it I will point
the server to the bucket where our model
would be exported to now in the workflow
page you can see that I have a serving
deployment called minced serve after
that let's also deploy a web app UI to
interact with the model here I have a
simple flask app that will connect with
the server that we deployed in an last
step again I have packaged it into a
container and pushed into the registry I
use case on it to deploy it with an
external IP back to the workflow page
you can see the web UI deployment is
also running now let's check on the
status of our training job it is still
running let's look at the locks okay it
is almost done almost 90% there now we
can click on the refresh button here you
can see the training is now over and the
model has been uploaded to the bucket
with that we can play with our model
let's go to our web app component find
the external IP connect to the server
here it is
we can then use that server to test on
some random images so the first one
we're seeing a picture of the
handwritten 0 and this giving the
correct predictions of the row with that
let's test on cup of other random images
we can see that's giving the correct
result so everything we just saw today
from training to serving to web app UI
is all happening on gke
kubernetes was cute though well Faye
that was amazing well thanks well now
you can't easily develop training and
deploy your machine learning models
everywhere on kubernetes thanks to keep
low I want to give a big shout out to
dance NJ who developed the demo material
please like comment and subscribe down
below and if your company's working on
any cool projects and you'd like to
reach out to the team go ahead and click
on the link down below as well
[Music]